Let's look at what each side of each of these equations simplifies to, to
figure out which equations are true. How about we start with this equation up
here. And let's go with the left hand side first. Inside the parentheses here,
we have 100 times 1000 which is 100,000, or 10 to the 5th power That means that
this side of the equation is equal to log base 10 of 10 to the 5th, and we know
that that is just equal to 5. Great. Now, on the other side we have log base 10
of 100 plus log base 10 of 1000. So, this is the same as log base 10 of 10
squared. Plus log based ten of ten cubed. That's just two plus three, or five.
So, this equation does check out. This side is equal to this side, which means
it is a true statement. Awesome. Let's go for our second one. We know that log
based ten of 100 is 2 and we know that log based ten of 1,000 is three. So that
means that this side is equal to 2 times 3 or 6. Now over here, we're adding
those two numbers we just multiplied. Log base 10 of 100, plus log base10 of
1000, as we saw on this side, is just equal to 2 plus 3, or 5. 6 is not equal
to 5, so this is not a true statement. And our third equation, finally. On the
left hand side we have log based 10 of 1,100. Let's see using our calculator,
what that equals. Log of 1,100 equals 3.04139 and so on. Let's write that down,
I'll just write some of the numbers, we know that it's rounded on the
calculator anyway. On to the right hand side. Now notice that this expression
is exactly the same as the one we already evaluated. On the left-hand side of
the previous equation. So we know that this, log base 10 of 100 times log base
10 of 1,000, equals 6. Now, 3.04 anything is not equal to six, so this equation
is not true either. The first equation we had is the only example of the
product property being used properly. The two numbers that we multiplied and
then plugged in as the input of our first log expression, each act as the
inputs for these separate logs over here that are then added together. We have
to be super careful about which numbers are multiplying and which quantities
we're adding when we use the product property. Great job.